bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je vous
parlais d'un outil qui est vraiment
génialissime pour réussir ses vidéos sur
youtube
et pour réussir de manière générale sur
youtube qui vous permet de trouver les
bons mots clés pour notre chaîne de
regarder la concurrence et de suivre
votre évolution de plus en plus de celle
d'un jour sur youtube et il est
extrêmement difficile de réussir je
partage avec vous toute mes astuces le
mur technique pour gagner des vues des
abonnés et enfin réussir sur youtube
envoyez vos vaches à lait active la
cloche pour ne manquer aucune
publication question du jour quels
outils utiliser vous pour réussir sur
youtube
est-ce que vous utilisez un outil en
particulier pour pouvoir connaître vos
mots clés
suivent au positionnement ou alors est
ce que vous faites ça un petit peu au
feeling quant à moi j'utilise un outil
qui est top j'utilise depuis maintenant
quelques mois il s'appelle tu me dis
alors je vous rassure tout de suite
cette vidéo n'est pas sponsorisé
personne ne paye pour le faire par
contre tu me dis c'est vraiment un outil
qui est très très très pratique pour
commencer je vais vous dire ce qu'est tu
me dis tu le dis c'est une sorte
d'application pour votre navigateur
moi j'utilise crown ça marche
extrêmement bien vous l'installer dans
votre navigateur il va se superposer
directement votre chaîne youtube par
exemple ici on à ma chaîne youtube
on a ici un petit icône qui nous qui
étudie en réalité et tu me dis je vais
pouvoir voir ici montre analytics qui me
permet effectivement d'avoir des
statistiques sur ma chaîne de voir le
nombre d'abonnés de voir un petit peu
l'évolution que j'ai eues dans les dents
le 28 d'un un jour et 30 derniers jours
donc là on voit très bien le nombre
d'abonnés le jus dernièrement les tags
de match n est
des informations un petit peu sur ma
chaîne en règle générale et surtout tu
veux dit va vous permettre effectivement
je dirais de faire augmenter votre
stratégie youtube d'aller plus loin il
trouvait les bons mots clés qui vous
permettront de vous positionner et
d'être découvert et ensuite
effectivement pas près de pouvoir être
actionnaire de tapas quand même pouvoir
s'abonner à votre chaîne globalement il
faut le voir comme un outil que vous
aidez à grossir votre business
et c'est super intéressant on va prendre
par exemple une de mes vidéos celle qui
a le mieux marché chez moi les rumeurs
l'iphone 8 300 7000 vue au jour
d'aujourd'hui ce qui est très
intéressant et que tu me dis c'est que
vous allez pouvoir avoir des infos sur
la partie droite on a plein plein plein
d'informations qui sont vraiment très
intéressante
le nombre de taxes de mots clés sur
lesquels je me référence et on les a ici
on a ensuite ici la liste et on voit
effectivement la position les taxes sur
lesquels sont référencés numéro un
numéro 2 et numéro 3 et c'est donc on va
en prendre une première fille est par
exemple comment sera l'iphone 8 vous
cliquez dessus ça vous ouvre le fameux
tag explorer de tubes de 10 on va dans
les résultats
et effectivement j'apparais bien premier
avec en dessous d'autres d'autres vidéos
qui sont référencés sur ce terme là par
exemple en train de regarder ma chaîne
ça me permet effectivement de voir mes
positions de pouvoir analyser les vidéos
nous peut faire exactement la même chose
sur les concurrents et c'est extrêmement
intéressant si par exemple dans votre
domaine vous trouvez un concurrent qui
réussit et vous pas trop vous pouvez
aller voir quels sont les mots clés sur
lesquels ils sont positionnés voir si
sur ces mots clés il ya un volume de
recherche s'ils athenian aussitôt une
énorme concurrence est globalement que
vous avez très très peu de chance de
vous positionner là dessus ça doit
vraiment une mine d'informations qui
vous permet de comprendre comment
trouver les bons mots clés comment les
utiliser pour pouvoir ensuite intégré
vous dans votre stratégie directement
sur votre chaîne on chez d'une manière
générale tu veux dit va vous aider à
trouver les bons mots clés et ça c'est
pour moi la fonction numéro 1 de tu me
dis je vous montre ça regardez là par
exemple je suis sur ma vidéo macbook pro
2010 est qu une vidéo qui a très bien
marché je vais me retrouver par exemple
à avoir ici mes mots clés sur lesquels
je suis positionné on prend aux hasards
par exemple macbook pro je vais me
retrouver avec dans la partie gauche des
mots clés qui ne sont suggérées que tu
me dis qu'on prend comme étant dans la
sémantique dans la même thématique
apple macbook touch bar review est
effectivement alors son macbook pro je
vois qu'ils ont voulu
de recherche mais aussi une forte
compétition que c'est très difficile de
se référencer mais ça si vous voulez
globalement c'est la méthode qui vous
permettent de progresser dans votre
recherche
goethe à trouver les bons mots clés des
mots clés sur lequel il ya volume de
recherche certains parce que si vous
cherchez des mots clés sur lequel n'y a
pas de volume il n'y a pas d'intérêt y
aura personne pour venir vous trouvez
donc des mots clés qui ont quand même un
volume de recherche et où il n'y a pas
trop de compétitions sur lesquelles vous
pouvez vous référencer alors ensuite
vous pouvez aller dans les autos
suggests suggestion automatique ça vous
proposer par exemple des mots clés qui
peuvent intéressant pour youtube pour
google os il faut pas négliger le
référencement google parce que vous
pouvez découvrir directement sur google
et les gens peuvent arriver ce mode
vidéo youtube par ce biais là donc ça
c'est intéressant par exemple macbook
pro 2016 par rapport aux 2017 je clique
dessus je vais sûrement résumé ça c'est
intéressant par exemple ça me marque ya
quand même un volume de recherche qui
est assez moyen donc il ya un volume de
recherche existants la compétition est
assez moyenne ce qui fait que on a
encore des chances de pouvoir se
positionner dessus même si la note
globale est pas extraordinaire avec un
titre bien optimisé des taxes bien poser
des solutions relativement bien écrite
vous pouvez encore vous référencer et ça
c'est super intéressant et c'est ce que
vous apporte une boutique il vous donne
un résumé et donne des suggestions et
vous propose des mots clés sur lesquels
vous pouvez effectivement essayé de vous
référencer ils vous donnent des
résultats pour voir quelles sont les
chaînes qui sont référencés sur ces mots
clés là ce qui vous permet aussi d'aller
voir les mots clés que eux ont utilisé
pour vous permettre de réussir
il ya toute une compréhension de l'outil
si vous voulez mais savons comment vous
permettre d'avoir les bonnes clés pour
réussir
on cite alors tout y est vraiment sympa
s'appelle le search ranking tool qui va
vous permettre de voir de suivre
l'évolution du positionnement de vos
mots clés de voir si vos mots clés se
positionne et si en gros vous pouvez
lier des positions et elle découvert par
rapport à ça je vous montre ça vous
voyez par exemple ici on voit très bien
comment s'est passée ma stratégie pour
gagner mais quelques 10000 vue on va
très bien qu'au début ce sont mes
quelques abonnés qu'ils ont vu ensuite
sur ce mois et demi il ya un petit creux
et ensuite j'ai commencé à gagner des
positions ici on envoie des vues
régulier donc ça c'est super intéressant
avec tube de 10 mais surtout ce qui est
super c'est de comprendre comment vos
mots clés sont référencés la progression
vous avez sont bons mots clés pour ça
vous allez dans toulouse en dessous de
la vidéo que ce soit sur votre chaîne à
vous ou sur d'autres chaînes
vous allez dans le cercle reinking
directement ici et là vous allez
retrouver vos mots clés
alors moi par exemple macbook pro 13
pour 13 pouces 2017 je suis positionné
en numéro 3 je clique dessus et là je
vois l'historique au 25 juillet j'étais
21 21 21 et la boum 3 et je verrai dans
le temps en fonction de la progression
j'ai passé deuxième et peut-être premier
donc ça c'est vraiment très intéressant
tu me dis vous permet également de
connaître le meilleur moment pour poster
votre contenu si vous voulez c'est une
analyse de votre chaîne qui va vous
donner le meilleur moment
par rapport aux interactions de vos
abonnés donc ça peut permettre
d'optimiser votre publication d'hier
j'ai publié le jour à telle heure ces
moments où mes abonnés sont là où ils
sont actifs et où ils verront moment où
je publie alors après il ya plusieurs
options vous avez soit une option
gratuite qui vous permet d'avoir des
fonctionnalités de base de découvrir
outils et qui est vraiment bien il y à
une version payante
il ya trois abonnements différents le
tout premier est à 9 euros
et si vous avez moins de cinq ans n'e
lui sur votre chaîne c'est moins cinq
ans portant sur le prix donc ça
fonctionne d'abonnement à 4 euros 4
euros 50 et je crois que ces quatre
dollars 50 qui au final est vraiment pas
cher donc ça permet d'avoir un outil pas
cher pour commencer a débuté et pour
réussir votre stratégie youtube
j'ai dû une fois de plus c'est pas là
pour vous pousser à la consommation mais
moi je me suis mis dessus et grâce à
l'analytique j'ai réussi à progresser un
autre truc est vraiment intéressant
c'est la possibilité de créer un
template pour aux miniatures au lieu de
vous embêter si vous maîtrisez pas un
photoshop
ghimpu n'importe quel ou cette édition
vous pouvez tout à fait définir que
votre texte sera là que vos couleurs
principales seront telle ou telle
couleur ça vous permettra d'optimiser et
d'aller très vite tout en tout cas
d'aller plus vite sur votre vignette sur
notre miniature alors ne pas la négliger
parce que ces cas restent quand même
l'élément fondamental pour que les gens
puissent cliquez sur votre vidéo il à
découvrir
mais ça vous permet effectivement match
serré de dalé un petit peu plus vite
d'abord un process un peu plus rapide et
ça c'est super intéressant un autre
point qui est super c'est une check list
vous avez une check-list en dix points
pour vous donner les actions à faire
quand vous mettez une vidéo est ce que
vous avez écrit à mon titre ce que vous
avez une bonne miniature trouver fait la
description est ce que vous avez l'été à
glace que vous avez fait c'est ce que
vous avez fait ça c'est un espèce de
pense bête pour vérifier si vous avez
tous si vous avez mis en place les
bonnes stratégies
moi ce que je vous conseille aujourd'hui
c'est de l'installer je vous mets un
lien ici vous pouvez cliquer dessus
allez voir installer le gratuitement et
sega lui regarder un peu ça correspond à
votre niche et si ça vous apporte des
éléments de réponse par rapport à votre
votre problématique sur youtube pour
réussir et pour trouver les bons mots
clés et celio gratuit est ce qu'il faut
ça vous intéresse et vous vous rendez
compte que c'est vraiment performant que
vous avez des petits abonnement le coût
est pas énorme mais par contre derrière
ce que ça va vous apporter un gain de
temps et en réussite sur youtube ça va
être énorme au lieu de passer des mois
et des mois pour trouver les bons mots
clés ça l'a tout de suite s'éclairer en
tout cas c'est comme ça que ça s'est
passé avec moi et vous allez voir vous
mélangez ça avec une bonne stratégie de
recherche de moc est d'ailleurs allé
voir cette vidéo elle devrait vous aider
aussi pour votre recherche de mots clés
un outil comme tu le dis vous le
mélanger avec du adwords nouvelle 13
normalement vous avez
la bonne stratégie pour retrouver vos
mots clés et pour réussir sur youtube
voilà pour cette vidéo j'espère qu'elle
vous aura idées n'hésitez pas à me
laisser des pousses bleus si vous avez
trouvé ça intéressant et si ça vous
apporter des éléments de réponse mettez
votre commentaire par rapport à la
question du jour que je vous ai posé
juste avant quant à moi je vous dis à
très bientôt j'en ramassais de regarder
ma vidéo n'hésitez pas à vous abonner si
ça vous intéresse pas ce que je veux
donner encore plus de conseils et bonnes
astuces pour réussir sur youtube pour
vous équiper pour avoir les bons outils
les bonnes stratégies et gagner du temps
éviter d'en perdre merci beaucoup et il
ya très bientôt salut